foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Taya Swenson writer
for Lords of Gaming
and back with me again is the Lord King
we're here talking about the second to
last episode of She-Hulk as it finally
happened another lawyer has hit the
scene as Daredevil made a splashing
entrance into the She-Hulk Series in
more ways than one king was going to
kick it off to you to break it down with
everyone's favorite hero LeapFrog
yo it was um
it was incredible to see that they're
taking John Burns comic book run with um
She-Hulk and doing everything that the
book did the book reinvigorated The
Character I changed it from a
one-dimensional character into a
four-dimensional character because you
know she's always breaking the fourth
wall and made her very interesting at
the same time the feminist movement is
going on and women is striving for
equality in the world the book was
um
a reflection of that you know giving
female empowerment you know she's not
like the Hulk she's not living in the
Hulk world and I think the series
captured that in a nutshell to be honest
with you but we always wondered about
her powers as uh um as a lawyer
and we fail to realize she just uh
passed the bar she just you know became
a lawyer when she was at her other firm
and then you know she was looking for
big raises and stuff like that and that
wasn't happening on that end and you
know now she got over to this big firm
and she's only hired because she's
She-Hulk so she relied on a lot of
different utensils uh to win in the
courtroom
but then when Matt Murdoch shows up and
he legally runs circles around her
inside the courtroom she's like what
like did that just happen and you know
he's
he's super enough to know exactly who
she is you know he's Suave enough to
know exactly to know that he's in
another superhero's town and not to step
on the toes and he sends over a drink at
the bar and they were having a little
moment there and if people don't know
the She-Hulk comic books she's a highly
sexual character so um you know as as
they say you know the Hulk rage you know
she has a rage too so she's even as
Jennifer Walters she's flirting with uh
Daredevil and Daredevils trying to give
us some insight on
being a a superhero while also being a
lawyer you know to take over
outside of the law if you know the law
doesn't work on our side and she's
listening and it's kind of the same
thing that Bruce was saying but Bruce
was telling her to be a hero and leave
her world what Daredevil said is you can
have the best of both worlds so her
willingness to listen to him and the
fact that she's attracted to him on a
professional level
was something incredible then she gets
to call and you know LeapFrog is like
help me you know as Daredevil is
attacking him so we find out she puts on
the suit that we all been dying to see
and the suit looks fantastic on her
whole purple and white suit and she
shows up sneakers and all and you know
she takes on Daredevil and Daredevil
doesn't disappoint
he out Maneuvers her he does a whole
bunch of superhero stuff but she Hawk
doesn't disappoint either you know she's
she's new at this but she she was able
to you know subdue him and find out
exactly who he was took his mask off
really quickly and I think that was an
aha moment for her
you know the aha moment for her was wow
you know this guy is doing this and he's
a lawyer he's a superhero and he's a
lawyer and then they went to the
warehouse to take down LeapFrog and it's
so much satire that's there I must say
this
LeapFrog is the dude when they first go
to
um to go see the tailor yes that's right
I was gonna say that's walking out yep
me and you agonized over this in the
background who the hell was that because
we knew it was an Easter egg that will
come back at some point in time and I
went back to our uh a previous DMS and I
was like yeah that's the back of his
head that's definitely to do and you
know I'm glossing over a lot of things
because you know I want my co-host to
actually you know talk about certain
things as well and you know they team up
in this in this team up mode and they
was trying to see who was going to take
the lead and Daredevils on foreign
ground because he's from New York and
you know he's like well let me I have
the expertise in this and she's like
well I do this too and he's like no you
don't you're playing around at it you're
dabbling it and you're not actually
putting your feet in it and you know
they actually successfully you know save
somebody from uh the warehouse they
actually take down you know uh
LeapFrog which is funny with his
headphones which is funny within itself
when he was saying a story in the
beginning
I'm like he's not a superhero he's an
actual villain a lot of the guys that
you saw that was introduced into this
show were villains the only two uh
Heroes that you saw was Wong he wasn't
introduced in Daredevil he's introduced
I love this purple and I mean um the
yellow and red suit
the yellow and red suit signifies the
beginning of Daredevil when he first was
in the Marvel Universe he was yellow and
red and then they went to the
traditional red and then they went to
the black and red and then all black and
then you know back but again to see that
that flare and to know that the only The
Stylist can do that and the fact that we
saw the intelligentity and what what
they whole plan was to do with her but
also to have Daredevil do the walk of
shame and the most commonplace things
that are going on now is when her uh
paralegal comes in and she says hey I
see a guy dressed up in the dead in the
devil suit you know doing the Walk of
Shame and they're joking around and
they're laughing but again this is
commonplace they're making Heroes
commonplace as more as as you can see it
so when they introduced these Heroes
there's not any question that this is
normalcy yeah yeah the biggest reveal in
this whole show was on her paralegal set
and jumped out with the Wolverine claws
and said at let's pretty you up
and I said hold on wait a second I
rewind that and that's she yeah she did
just do that very specifically
and she displayed so that means that
there is a wolverine in that world is it
Hugh Jackman we don't know but right
there is a wolverine that is persistent
within that world and so is a lot of
other heroes and villains so because she
breaks the fourth wall at the end again
and she lets it go is it a red Hulk yeah
when she said Red Hulk away all red
shield yo this is ridiculous so yeah
I'll let you fill in the gaps on all
other stuff and uh it was a it was
I'm glad they did it how they wanted to
do it I'm glad it wasn't a super serious
Daredevil tone and it was more of a
jokey sensual Daredevil that plays into
the Daredevil Elektra stuff that I used
to get out of Frank Miller books where
Daredevil was uh a ladies man uh because
his powers actually lean towards the the
ability to touch and understand things
more than the average man so he is The
Man Without Fear I actually like what
they did with it so I I got a little bit
of Frank Miller and John Byrne all in
one uh series I'm I'm good with it yeah
um so I'll start with with uh the last
bit and kind of work backwards in that
I'm glad that uh the walkashame of
Daredevil was a was presented such a
healthy healthy manner of um sexual
relationships from an adult perspective
because he was doing the walk of shame
but like he was whistling and Sherry
happens like morning how's it going uh
so like that that was very happy for me
to see and this entire episode
I was almost grinning ear the entire
time because of everything that was
happening
um and as cliche as it sounds and we'll
see how the final episode shapes up I
didn't want this to be my favorite
episode because then it'll boil down to
well yeah of course it's the favorite
Daredevil popped in but there were so
many good moments and great
um
a great plot development that happened
uh in here we had talked before on okay
what's gonna be the the over the edge
point for Jennifer to finally start
committing to actually fighting crime
outside the courtroom and Daredevil was
that Catalyst we saw
um after the confrontation fight between
them and him giving you know the sage
advice uh echoing Bruce but being like
hey like this is possible you can you
see I'm a lawyer as well and and I do
both things um fighting in the courtroom
and on the streets
um and for her to be like you know what
yeah of uh donning that super suit and
charging at first and to being giddy not
only to you know try and impress Matt
Murdoch but also being like yeah I can
be a superhero too
and I love I love the camaraderie
between the two the chemistry was there
uh from frame one and
as you mentioned I love that this Matt
Murdock is completely different from
when we last left him in the Netflix
series he's more cheery he uh has more
Charisma about him he's not dumagloom
and they even make a joke uh later on of
him brooding on the lily pad sign but
that's just not his personality 24 7.
and in the court case with LeapFrog and
uh Luke Jacobson
um
he does Echo that he still has on the
Forefront of his mind protecting his
loved ones and how important a secret
identity is which is something that he
had difficulty coming to grips with much
of Netflix
um he definitely suffered from the uh
well I have to forever be alone I can't
be with anyone can't have anyone close
to me
um but now for him to essentially take a
step into the light and more optimistic
side of having a healthy balance about
himself that we do have grave
responsibilities that we need to take
care of but that can't consume us um if
we are going to be heroes to everyone
big or small
um
so I like that lesson that they were
pushing forward uh I'm glad that they um
or how they got in that legal court case
with LeapFrog LeapFrog
suit malfunctioned
um but it was user error and of course
you got the suit from Luke so that legal
thing went out I also liked how they
brought up the sokovia Accords yes yes
that sounds big
yeah yeah so those officially have been
repealed
um but Daredevil you know it's moving
his way through the courtroom won the
case of course and uh Luke and Jennifer
did make it up at the end after Jennifer
had to save Luke from LeapFrog
kidnapping him
um but when we get through the the
rescuing after uh Daredevil and Jennifer
was like oh yeah we're on the same side
like your client is the reason we're in
this mess exactly
um and that when uh we went the
Daredevil way first you know half an
hour sneaking around when they went to
that hallway I was like it's the hallway
and then and they were setting it up for
it to be like okay this one's break and
then Jennifer like smashes through when
you thought it was really about to go
down I thought that was classic it was a
good blend between the two because we we
got enough of the Daredevil fight and we
knew how this fight was pretty much
gonna go yep yep yep
um but uh that transpired of you know
her doing her smash thing and it was
like it's like a classic comic shot shot
of they enter into the den of the
villains and they're like oh oh oh yo
She-Hulk it's this Horn Guy like what
are we gonna do like Tad ball too
tadwell too what we gonna do and you
know Jennifer just like yeah yeah do you
really want to do that was just like
obvious that's so comics and I loved it
um so that transpired and then you know
uh they had been setting little things
here and there you know the little lean
ins like oh your hearts beating kind of
fast Jennifer is like oh like he's doing
it for me and I'm like he's doing it for
me too let's get it and then and then I
loved how she wasted no time like are
you going to New York tomorrow I was
like yeah I can get you dinner when I
come no no we're gonna skip all that
you know what I like and what I
appreciate sorry to cut you off
that he liked her yes yes
that you know and and I guess that leads
to a little bit of validation for for
Jen because he was thoroughly uh
infatuated with the thought of her and
not the thought of She-Hulk which was
exactly
yeah yeah yeah I appreciate that he
definitely he saw equally the charm
um within hurricane and as She-Hulk uh
and I very much appreciate that and
appreciate the the maturity of these two
adults hitting it all off enjoying
working together and whatnot and um
basically sealing the deal toward the
end and a healthy and safe manner
um and I was with Jennifer we had a
fourth wall break moment of where that
sun was setting and I was like ah okay
like I'm good and they kept going we see
daredev walking off like
okay and then Jennifer's walking he's
like y'all still here I'm like yeah why
are we still here and we get into the
gala which I was like oh well the gala
like
they were playing up on the audience's
thoughts of they're probably thinking oh
like this episode's still going we get
to the gala we see her in her nice dress
by Luke looking stunning
um and she gets the guy in which
um forgot to mention earlier
um Mr Mr slimy with the new wakanda
spear is also at the gala in which both
you and I that like something is off
with that guy he tried to get Jennifer
to help him with a legal case of wakanda
wants to spare back that was auctioned
off
um because of the colonizers stealing
their stuff and then he tried to get to
schmoove at first I thought he was going
to whip it out when he was like oh yeah
I got this wakan spear here there's
something not right with him and then he
was at the gala we just see him at the
beginning when he's waving I'm like this
I'm not right with him and we don't see
him again and then she gets the female
lawyer of the Year award but it's not
just I guess it's every female in the
house that was a little inside joke and
you know how women in the market uh the
business world
aren't taking uh aren't taking as
seriously as the men and he did say you
know a a little off-handed uh backhanded
compliment to uh the female of the Year
yep you know in the beginning and my
wife looked at me like what the hell was
that and I was just like I don't know
but it seems like it's setting up for
something stupid and then it was like 10
women up there and it was kind of
degrading within itself but you know she
didn't see it as a degree in the moment
actually she saw it as a a real
achievement to you know say you know
because she hasn't been in this space
that long yep and you know it's a thing
called parents so you know it's it's
something that was uh
you see
she does she's so naive she's still at
the naive space where she doesn't
understand somebody's making a fool of
her yep somebody's taking advantage of
her and then I guess the intelligentia
stuff pops up at that same moment and
the level of anger because remember she
was the better people jokes in college I
mean in school you know in college too
you know so all the way through she's
been like little gin who can little Jen
who did this a little Jen who's always
behind the eight ball and you know the
wedding accentuated that aspect of it
and right now she's being acknowledged
for work that she's done and she feels
accomplished and she's in this wonderful
uh dress that looks fantastic and she's
at the top of the world she just slept
with somebody that actually likes her
and you know that's in the same
profession so her life feels like it's
rolling on all cylinders and to have
that stuff crash down on her for her for
her to have a mental break at that
moment and to know how Bruce feels
at that moment when she's looking around
and everybody is screaming because those
are the same people that had adulation
for now have terror in the eyes and fear
and that is directed exactly towards her
and my wife said at the end
I don't know if she's looking at the
screen because I said that she broke the
fourth wall when she looked at the
screen like what the hell did I do yeah
and she said no I think she's looking at
someone because she said she recognizes
the difference when she looks at the
screen and looks at someone so uh me and
her has a a knee bet for that yeah yeah
well yeah we'll see when that scene
broke down and her at first I was like
yep well deserved just tear it down this
is taking too long
um and when the crowd start the alarms
came on and I guess that triggered the
crowds to start running because I was
like why y'all running like y'all saw
was up there and I felt like this this
different from everything else that Jen
had to suffer with as a breaking point
because it was setting up as you know um
we'll show you who She-Hulk really is
and at first she's like oh I'm like my
identity is not a secret yeah all right
to her those moments that were being
posted and everything especially the
bedroom scene with Josh
it's it's like nothing nothing at all is
ever sacred in our life anymore the one
time that she thought she was safe in a
vulnerable private moment now is being
blared to the public once again
um and that she was actually being taken
advantage of and made to look like a
fool
um and all this other nonsense I can see
how it was a
um sent her over the edge but even then
when she broke out and she saw you know
intelligent Geo goons in the corner and
She chased after them and she had one up
I still feel like it was a controlled
rage like she wasn't just raging like
she immediately drops them when by the
way I don't know how but the anti-super
squad was there like that I'm like how
are they on speaker it was this it was a
setup right exactly like there's no way
they were called they were already there
waiting and perhaps
um so it's a terrible situation that she
finds herself in and where next episode
picks Pixar I think
to me when she looked at the screen I
thought she was also breaking the fourth
wall because it was a it was a moment of
uh Clarity of um from her to the
audience of like oh crap wow I really
stepped in it yeah
yeah
uh so we'll see again
all this setup and everything
intelligent Shield Hulk King we still
don't have a face to a name of who the
Grand Master is the leader yeah yeah
yeah so we have the leader as our bets
uh and we got the pull for homegirl Jen
it's gonna be a crazy last episode to
wrap everything up and set her up uh in
the future of the MCU we had a whole lot
of drops
um Wolverine references Red Hulk
references uh and all these teeterings
I've been setting up
um into something more and very excited
to see where we go from here
definitely
um like I said every week I'm fully uh
surprised and I'm thoroughly entertained
but this has been the Lord's minute
thank you so much for joining us we're
here every Monday Wednesday and Friday
at lordsagaming.net I'm ty Swenson here
with Lord King and this has been
the Lord's minute peace
[Music]